in any job there are sacrifices in any
relationship their sacrifices every job
requires compromise in different
circumstances you need to do things that
you don't necessarily want to do because
it's part of your job obviously there
were a lot of hopes or dreams that I had
and those things coming true it it kind
of makes you want to keep dreaming more
what's that believe nation it's evan my
one word is believe and i believe that
you have the ability to do something
special that can change the planet so to
help you on your journey today we're
going to learn from actress Emma Stone
and my take on her top ten new rules for
success rule number five is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys liked the best
I think keep making your own stuff
that's a big big thing if that was I
wish I had known that early on because I
was auditioning a lot and waiting for
other people to give me a chance and now
the internet and all these other outlets
you can write your own things and act on
your own stuff and just make really
incredible you know incredible projects
without having to wait for someone else
to tell you yes so you keep making your
own stuff I mean I was fifteen when I
came out to LA to audition so I don't
think I was even you know cooking with
all four burners and it's one of those
things where you're like I'm so lucky to
be doing this that it's not like you can
really complain but I missed going to my
best friend's wedding because of it so
it's like there are those things but I
think we all have that I mean in any job
there are sacrifices in any relationship
they're sacrifices we're all as human
beings dealing with that balancing all
the things that we we want to do and we
dream of doing with our responsibilities
and our relationships and yeah so two
options you either follow my rules or
follow my rules
capiche thank you I can do it a
different way that's that's fine thank
you very much when you were starting out
what was your experience like in those
audition waiting rooms similar to what
you saw in the movie not quite as
Musical but how did you get through
dinner rejections just keep your head up
and keep going I think you know if
you're trying to act there will be a lot
of rejection that is part of the process
it never stops it continues now like
there are parts that you want now that
don't come to you it's just it just is
what it is it's like being human yeah
there's lots of rejection and being
human it's just it's just part of it I
think it you know and it can be really
crushing but it also is not life
threatening thankfully you think at some
point in this business you need to
compromise or it's possible to just not
compromise on anything and pursue what
you think is the right thing to do mm-hm
I mean I think when it comes to the work
you choose to do it depends on your the
way you are your makeup your financial
state okay
things I mean I think that some I'm sure
some people go through without
compromising at all and some people go
through compromising well all the time
it's just it just depends I think that
every job requires compromise in
different circumstances you need to do
things that you don't necessarily want
to do because it's part of your job but
yeah I I don't know I guess it just
depends on the person like what the view
point is you think generally speaking in
your career as an actress have you had
to compromise a lot or not not in terms
of roles that I've chosen or that I've
wanted to be a part of I know I've
chosen every single one that's yeah I
haven't done anything because I felt
like I had to or because I was being
forced to but I was also lucky because
if I wasn't able to pay my rent you damn
well better believe I would take
something that was a compromise I think
that's very so I understand how lucky
that is and in you know in a huge way
when you have the Rose heater and the
help and then you're playing Gwen Stacy
yes Piderman the internet buzzes because
they always have somebody else in mind
they'll say Dain Julie Dench should
definitely have been Gwen's I know you
know I know who is this enema stone
that's playing this thing where does she
come from to do that so it has no effect
on you no I mean it of course it does
and I had to put the computer down
because I knew instantly and that was
you know I was almost kind of grateful
that I was shooting the help when I
auditioned because I knew what it was
like to feel backlash already of you
know people who loved that book so much
and did not think I was right for a
skater and I completely understand
because I read the book and neither do I
I just felt incredibly lucky and how do
you say no to an opportunity like you
know you don't but I okay there came a
point where I was like I'm not gonna
sleep at night if I if I go and I do or
all quit or I won't challenge myself I
won't let myself do something like this
because I feel unworthy of playing a
part like that the same goes for Gwen
and you
just go alright well I'm gonna do the
best that I can
as an actor I'm only one person I'm
gonna fulfill it in any way that I
possibly can and work the hardest that I
personally can and that's that's all you
can really do what advice would you give
you younger self when you think back to
those days I actually don't really know
that I would tell myself anything
because I feel happy to be where I am
now and I feel like it all sort of
unfolds in the way it's meant to unfold
so I wouldn't want to like change any
course stolen credits her parents as
well as her teacher for supporting her
acting dreams maybe was my first grade
teacher mrs. Goldman because she put me
in the first grade play and that was
like one enormous moment I didn't
understand that I didn't know you know
at six years old what it was like to be
onstage or what it would feel like and I
was um I was pretty hooked but I didn't
start acting until like five years later
in a new theatre after I begged my
parents and that I begged and begged and
begged for them to take me to this
theatre so I could audition and it took
me like a month to convince them that I
wanted to be an actor cuz no one in my
family is you know yeah anyway and part
of that the thing that I've that I've
learned more this year is that I had a
lot of obviously there were a lot of
hopes or dreams that I had and those
things coming true it it kind of makes
you want to keep dreaming more you know
and keep thinking of the things that
will excite your and I I don't think I
knew how much I loved challenges until
Birdman came along and then and then
cabaret because I was scared I was
really I was scared it's it's um for me
it's a very very different thing and I
didn't know that I was scared to really
go there but I was and Alejandro sort of
terrified me and then breaking through
it just it's been like the most
rewarding it was the most rewarding work
I've ever gotten to do
you have any urge at all to be the
biggest movie star in the world is that
part of any of your drives wait you mean
I'm not a few hours I uh I don't know I
don't know that's that's the driving
urge but is it ever I mean do you get
your head turned by it or is it to be
the biggest movie stars well you know
the whole celebrity you know being one
of the biggest stars or is what do you
think it's not what I get it's not the
reader I feel like I get the feeling
that you would rather just go do your
work yeah it's definitely I mean I think
that um there's there's really not much
that you can complain about in a way
that makes any logical sense with the
kind of wonderful elements that come to
doing the job that I get to do but I
don't
III would not say that I have the
mentality of like any more more more
like bigger bigger bigger that's not
ever no ever the driving because you
could say to your agents I want to do a
studio movie that's gonna you know have
a tutor my dollar budget and I need to
be the lead and yeah I don't think that
the that the idea of the movie what the
movie is without like a story or a
script or a person making it behind it
it's gonna be my my driving force yeah
you might end up being a Star Wars movie
because you find it interesting exactly
I was in the spider-man movies because I
found not interesting and it was you
know though that was an incredible
experience during both of those so yeah
but I yeah I think it just really really
does depend on the project and I would
try not to be the kind of had the kind
of fear that oh this is too big or this
is too small ever about anything I think
it's just what what hits first I was
afraid oh I got I can move lower mmm
first I was afraid I was petrified kept
thinking I could never live without you
by my side but then I spent so many
nights thinking how you did me wrong and
I grew strong
and I learned how to get along and so
you're back give to March from outer
space I just walked in to find you here
with that sad look upon your face I
should have changed that stupid lock I
should have made you leave your key if
I'd have known for just one second you'd
be back to bother me go on now go walk
out the door just turn around now see
cuz you're not welcome anymore weren't
you the one who tried to hurt me with
goodbye do you think I'd crumble did you
think I lay down and die oh no not I I
will survive Oh as long as I know how to
love I know I'll stay alive I got all my
life to live and I got home alone again
and I saw her Oh Elsa hey hey
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Namrata she
wrote on for the next top 10 check out
the link in the description and go and
have your say finally you want to give a
quick try the to Jennifer price Jen
thank you so much for one your help in
writing the book and sitting with me and
doing all the interviews as well as you
picked up a copy of the book and took a
picture and post it on Facebook I
appreciate all your support and it was
great to have you with me on that
journey to me so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
the world has been so so insane for a
very long time but this year has been
like shockingly horrible and if people
can find joy for two hours and sitting
in a theater and dreaming and being
transported and I get to be part of
something like that it's it's an amazing
feeling I really didn't have friends in
the city for quite a while when I first
moved there because I was 15 and I was
home-schooled and there wasn't really a
place to meet people when you're in that
circumstance so movies affected me so
much in so many periods of time
especially in lonely periods or anxious
periods that really it feels so great to
be part of something that might help
people in that way you ever get sick of
working well I'm not working right now I
mean well it feels like we're we're sure
if know I've had a while office I mean I
don't I don't think I ever get sick of
working I think I just get I've gotten
I've had periods of time where I've
gotten really tired or I felt like I
don't have enough to give me and but
yeah I don't think the work itself is
ever what I guess I guess ever what is a
crazy audition that you had early on you
know we are here at the Screen Actors
Guild Awards getting that sag card is a
really big deal in the beginning do you
remember kind of a an audition that made
you freak out a little bit I think I
mean I relate to pretty much every
audition in the movie I've had a version
of the
many many times I think the hardest part
was for a while I auditioned for a lot
of things which is great when you're an
actor and you're getting a lot of
auditions and I wasn't getting called
back for anything when I first moved to
LA and and so they just stopped sending
me out so there was a large swath of
time where nobody wanted me to even come
in and I think that feeling was actually
worse than any of the you know the
initial auditions and being kind of
rejected